this is for people who care about the
work that I do I want to tell you about
The Newsroom which is just a fancy title
for our patreon where you get a lot of
fun things and you can simultaneously
support what we're doing around here
what is it that we're doing around here
oh you know just low-key trying to
change how journalism is done I left Vox
in 2019 to start doing journalism on my
own and now we are at 3 million
subscribers I used Wii because it's no
longer just me it is now a big team of
very talented people who make all of
this happen to do really good journalism
more and more we need to rely on support
from the community so that's where the
newsroom comes in you help support
independent journalism and the good
thing is you get something in return
every month we do a behind the scenes
Vlog where you get to meet the people
behind the scenes see our processes see
a lot of shenanigans it's a really good
time but you also get to weigh in on the
thumbnails and the titles that we choose
even story ideas you get access to my
scripts the full uncut interviews that I
do with experts and every month you get
a music track from our composer Tom Fox
that you can use in your own videos so
go check out The Newsroom if it's not
your thing that's fine if it is your
thing I'll see you over there